Щорічне зростання економіки України на 5-7%,
жодних хабарів та корупції.
Новий прем’єр-міністр Олексій Гончарук
щедро роздає амбітні обіцянки.
- Ми досі не впоралися з тим,
що хтось приходить до влади для того, щоб щось "пилити".
У новому уряді красти не будуть.
Обіцянка нового прем’єра далеко не нова.
Чи не кожен український уряд декларував  боротьбу з корупцією.
Утім, успіхи в цій царині досі залишаються вельми скромними.
Чи є підстави сподіватися, що з новим урядом все буде інакше?
Як оцінюють склад та перші кроки нового Кабміну
активісти-антикорупціонери?
З одного боку, в уряд нарешті прийшли молоді й нові обличчя -
те, чого хотіли українські виборці.
Середній вік нового Кабміну - 39 років.
Це наймолодший уряд у Європі.
З іншого боку, деякі кадрові призначення
та реорганізаційні кроки викликали скепсис у громадських активістів.
Найбільше нарікань на те, що
на посаді міністра внутрішніх справ залишився Арсен Аваков.
З усім корупційним шлейфом, який
тягнеться за ним уже кілька років поспіль.
Починаючи з гучної справи про рюкзаки для армії
й закінчуючи тим, що напади на активістів,
які борються з чиновниками-корупціонерами,
почастішали, а кримінальні справи,
пов’язані з цими нападами, досі залишаються нерозкритими.
На думку виконавчої директорки
Центру протидії корупції Дар’ї Каленюк,
новий уряд уже має ознаки того, що
реформа МВС і Нацполіції не буде доведена до кінця.
- Лишити Авакова на посаді - це якийсь борг перед Коломойським
чи то особистий борг Зеленського перед Аваковим
за те, що допоміг провести вибори чесно.
Насправді в нас відбулося зрощення
криміналітету з представниками поліції.
Особливо сильно це відчувається в регіонах,
де людина почуває себе абсолютно незахищеною,
де місцеві царьки, князьки та олігархи можуть
повністю домовитися з поліцією, як знищити
якогось активного громадянина,
який намагається відстоювати свої права.
Як саме влада на місцях може погрожувати й тиснути
на викривачів корупції і яка пасивна при цьому поліція і прокуратура,
з власного досвіду знає запорізька активістка Наталія Заболотна.
Вона теж категорично проти Арсена Авакова в новому уряді.
Проте ще більше її непокоїть те, як непрозоро стартував новий уряд.
Кілька років поспіль Заболотна проводила для держслужбовців
у різних регіонах роз’яснювальну роботу з ось таким слоганом.
Її меседж: якщо у чиновників виникають
приховані від преси та громадськості інтереси,
то йдеться, швидше за все, про корупційні дії.
Заболотну непокоїть, що приховано від преси та громадськості
формувався, власне, новий уряд:
у закритому режимі, без обговорення з громадськістю
і обґрунтування тих чи інших кадрових призначень.
- Зараз ми бачимо такий, знаєте,
як "человек с бульвара Капуцинов"…
Я хочу монтаж: є ідея, є готове рішення.
Що, яка мотивація, які рішення,
хто приймав рішення, хто їх виробляв?
Є порушення Закону "Про доступ до публічної інформації".
Нема публічного обговорення.
Це дуже важливі питання, які мали б
виноситися на громадське обговорення.
Занепокоєння експертів викликає i об’єднання в одне низки міністерств,
зокрема в об’єднанні міністерства екології
з міністерством енергетики міститься
низка корупційних загроз, переконаний політолог Віктор Таран.
- Екологи повинні захищати надра
від надмірного споживання і створити контроль.
А енергетики, навпаки, зацікавлені в тому, щоб
побільшу виробляти генерацію.
Вони повинні були б балансувати, а зараз ми розуміємо,
що є ризик, що почнеться видобування надр
без будь-якого контролю.
Громадськість може також втратити контроль
і за рішеннями уряду щодо аграрного сектора, ринку землі.
На думку експерта, це може стати наслідком
об’єднання аграрного міністерства з міністерством економіки і торгівлі.
Ключове питання - що буде з земельними кадастрами,
земельним фондом у період, поки нове міністерство
ще лише формує законодавчу базу і визначається з повноваженнями.
- Три мільйони гектарів землі напередодні земельної реформи зависають у повітрі.
Це величезний шмат
для корупційних ризиків,
за який олігархи будуть дуже раді вчепитися.
У громадських активістів є також занепокоєння
і щодо роботи міністерства охорони здоров’я,
якому за останні роки вдалося майже неможливе:
зробити прозорими державні закупівлі ліків і медобладнання.
Також важливо й те, кого призначать
заступниками і держсекретарями міністерств.
- Перша така посада - це державний секретар,
який після реформи держслужби відповідає
за весь апарат, державні закупівлі, за розробку стратегії міністерств.
По суті, держсекретар - це буде та шия,
яка буде крутити міністром,
який, по суті, виконує представницькі функції.
З 5 вересня в Україні нарешті запрацює
Антикорупційний суд, який виноситиме вироки корупціонерам.
Результати його роботи стануть маркером
для громадських організацій. А також те,
чи буде новий уряд залучати громадськість
до обговорення своїх планів чи рішень.
Поки робота уряду доволі втаємничена:
засідання Кабміну проводять у закритому режимі.
- У нових міністрів і в нового керівництва
департаментів в уряді буде досить складний моральний вибір.
Або
просто брати ключі, вставляти їх в автомобіль
і їхати далі на корупційних схемах,
або відмовитися від цього й ламати систему.
Ламати ж систему дуже складно.
Це громадські активісти знають із власного досвіду.